Welcome to Super Family's 12th... I mean 11th... 12th...
Amanda, this isn't your job. Well, welcome to the Super Family's 12th movie, the Final Vow...
Welcome to the Super Family's 12th movie, the Final Vow...
I'm a little interrupted. Welcome to the Super Family's 12th movie, the Final Vow between Makuta and Super Family.
Right now, Super Family's hiding out in an underground... under, um... underground.
Well, we can't tell you because we don't want you bad peoples coming out there telling them Makuta is.
Did you hear something? Oh, argh!
I can't see you!
No smoking, no kicking the screen, no punching the screen, no flash photography even though you don't really need to.
By the time you do that to me, my vision won't be the easiest.
Well, as I've said, it was kindly doing the rules for me.
Isn't that ironic?
Okay, this movie has a couple of new characters, and I'm going to explain them.
Do you want me to get the lightsaber out?
Bruzy, a cruiser cruiser, White Stripe, a limo, Moonglaze and the Sun Giant, two baby badgers, two new ones, um, of course the Transformers,
Honey and Icy, two new punch buggies, and four! Count them.
FOUR!
New babies from Flies and Cornflower, Emerald, Jewelry, Chocolate, and of course the butter I call, you know since in our last template.
I think I'm going to put them all, of course all the mini-kinds, you know.
Keep an eye on Tahoe, don't tell him I said that because if you mention anything, even to the audience, I shouldn't have said that because one of you bad peoples might go tell him.
Oh, sorry, I am cold. Just go on with your little show.
Um, well, I'm not going to tell you guys.
Do you have any announcements? Do you have any other announcements?
Yeah, you don't really need to know what I'm going to say, but here's the movie.
Boy, great movie, Gally.
Lay, Tahoe and Gally, sitting in a tree.
Can you please not do that?
Sorry.
I hate being cooped up in a stupid place like this.
Why can't we have our old hideout back?
Aces destroyed.
Destroyed.
Eat it.
Well, I guess, hm, I wanna just find Makuta and give him peace of mind mine.
Freakin' weasel.
It's a Layla.
Yeah, but you got that new tidal wave technique, right?
Yeah.
Why'd you use it on me?
Be sure you wanna say that.
Yeah?
Hey, that's cool for surfing.
Okay, can you stop it?
It's starting to hurt.
Maybe the kids are getting breakfast.
Oh, no.
Hey, kids, you want some breakfast?
Yeah, we do.
Alright, let me go through the different ones we have.
Okay, we have
Kopaka
sugar-frosted, sugar-coated sugar lumps.
Makes your dentist scream.
Freeze
secret summoner game inside.
Vahivictuals.
Even though
I have all the time in the world, there's still
not enough time to eat my fill
of Vahivictuals.
And
Mata Nui Munch.
Yum! Even the great beings
can't resist Mata Nui Munch's
great taste. It's food for the gods.
Huh?
Side effects may include gas and
becoming infected.
What was that? Oh.
You mean the gummy craw-tie. You're not having them.
Pohatu's
ultra-crunchy jawbreakers.
Huh?
The crunch is actually your teeth,
not the cereal itself.
I don't think we're going to be having those today.
I don't think so.
Alright, what's the next one?
Holly's ga-coro flakes
with crunchy
lily-pad bits.
And frosted Takanuva flakes.
Four super-tricks.
Recharge with sugar.
And we have total.
Lavoq's super-sour
acid blasts.
Of course we have that.
Their unity, their duty,
and their stomachs I must
shatter.
Kids, that one goes in the dark.
Cool.
Plasma Pops. The only cereal you can drink.
Oh.
Kuma Nui sugar-cutter maple-colored
chocomeled tummy yummies.
You want that, kids? It says
grrr. Even giant Rahi
like me love to eat, um,
whatever you call this stuff.
Mmm.
So you want that, kids?
Yeah! K.
So you want Kuma Nui sugar-cutter
maple-colored double chocomeled tummy yummies?
Yeah! Okay.
Serve them up, Stacy.
Smash is fake. He's been forcing
us into this little place.
I don't,
I just don't like it here because
remember how peaceful our old AC
was? But now look at it.
Do you think we should go destroy
Makuta tomorrow? Or maybe tonight?
Do you wanna go
tonight, kids? It's possible.
Can't say we lost if we didn't try.
I know.
But it's just
scary.
We should go tonight.
This seems safer. We should go tonight.
Okay. I'm gonna
go to bed.
Do you even have the guts
to talk about plans
when Makuta's not here?
Of course I do.
Why would I be talking?
We have the Rahkshi,
whose hunger will consume them.
The Rahk, whose poison
will threaten people
who can shatter the very elements
of them. Pond Rahk,
who can destroy.
Tu Rahk, the leader
of the Rahkshi, master.
We will not lose
this. Do you kids want to start a little game of
football?
Do you want kids
to start a game of football?
Get it. It's just football.
And in this book right here
on page two
it tells you all the rules of football.
Starting now. Let's pick teams.
I don't care. We're playing now.
In the meantime, tricks money.
Three advanced staffs.
See? Three
advanced staffs. Wait a minute.
They're quick.
Hmm.
And I got one beginner staff
for anybody. Anybody want
a beginner staff? Four captains
and four teams since we have
four goalie sticks.
Unless the referee wants to have this one.
Yeah, the referee can have
the beginner. Who wants to be the referee?
What's your team going to be?
And the goalies.
Hit it in the air on some ice caps?
Let's get organized. This will be a little different.
What's your team going to be called?
Chocolate. Holy ball.
One team. Group together
then they flip against each other.
I'll see you guys first. You're green side.
Let's go against you two. You're blue side.
You're green side.
Yes. Attention.
All are required to report
to the launching pad
at this current time.
This is not a group. You must head out.
Okuda has located us.
Let's just go. Once again.
This works.
Throw things on the...
Can we get it done?
Yeah.
That's much better.
I don't know.
Definitely strange.
See anything?
What's this? Looks like a security camera.
Huh.
Should we destroy it?
Looks deactivated.
Wait. I'm going to swap you.
Yeah.
I'm going to make you our doom battle droids.
Why?
You need to rest.
Do you need to rest? No.
Why are you turning it off?
See look. There's the exit.
Slash him.
Take him down. Exit Stacey.
That's one. We'll get out of here.
Yesterday. Today.
Look at it.
Together they try not to.
Well.
That actually gives them good luck since
it's cramping.
Well. My other mask does
look good when I do this.
Actually it's got these little things there too.
Right.
I don't feel before then.
Well no. You stay here. I'll go back.
Really?
I can see it just ahead. Is everybody ready?
Yeah.
Okay. Let's head in.
Meet again Makuta.
But this time
we will win.
Haha. Well.
Say hello to my new friends.
Get ready.
For they are
the Rahkshi.
The Rahkshi? Yes.
The most powerful beings
in the universe.
You. Well.
I am the most powerful being.
But they are one of them.
You'll never stand a chance against
them. Prepare yourself.
White and shiny.
Very sharp you know.
Just like jelly. I'll jab it into the ground.
Good thing you stopped them from using it.
Me not. They. Dodge. Make sure you don't
bend myself.
Get him.
Get your wing out of my.
That's why I can't fight.
Makuta made me from scrap parts and I'm still as good as this.
Me Barry?
Me you fool. Hyper beam.
I blocked it. I dare you to try it again.
Finger nail.
You've done some pretty significant training.
Yes.
Well anyway Makuta. Look. You're broken.
I can fix that.
Don't you get it.
I'm much more powerful than I was.
What about your mask? You don't have it.
Huh? They're back.
Oh no. Not easy.
Now we have to go through this horror all over.
Your crown is gold.
Huh? You weren't supposed to see that.
Well I did.
Oh shut up.
Chat doesn't go up.
You have got to be the most annoying thing
ever in the world.
Thing? I'm a he.
Rocket man. Shattered.
Recover.
That kind of helped. But not for long.
I'm gonna tear into you so bad
you'll have to use a band-aid.
No. Not the dreaded
band-aids.
My masks are blast resistant.
Well they're hit resistant.
Well how about
TV. That was cheap.
Well now I've got this.
Well now I've got this mask.
Now you can rip in agony.
Hey wait a minute.
You said you got the mask.
I can't. The mask is lying.
You're an idiot.
Duh duh duh duh duh duh duh duh.
This is as crazy as
a Fourth of July.
Sun in
Cornflower's room. Hey cool.
No more tricks. Like the last time
we battled.
Wrapped in the water.
Fire in the sky.
I can't get that mask.
Um.
Okay that was just weird.
You're not doing that to me this time. Oops.
Those are my pins.
Cool. They're like lightsabers.
I am the force.
Hey let's have a lightsaber battle.
I'll use this.
Use the force. I must stab
out.
Hip Yoda is. Pierced his ear.
Yoda has. What is.
Succeeded. I have. Geez this is
way too easy for my liking.
Yes. I'm going to fix it.
Um. Scaly side.
Now I'm a different color.
Heya heya heya heya heya
heya heya heya. We need the rock.
I was taking a shower.
You're not supposed to be taking a shower at the job my son.
Your son? You've had another?
Who's your wife?
I don't even want to talk about that.
Okay. This is just getting
freaky.
And then kill you.
That tickles.
Baby badgers.
I'm going to have to come out in my
true form.
Dad don't you think that's a bad idea?
Um. Why?
I'll just. I'll just.
I'm going to shreds.
What I'm saying is that
we could.
It's not a good idea. We should wait until Dr.
But that's too long.
It's almost a week.
Those you see before you are battling you.
Who's before me?
Those three.
Those big three monsters.
Scary. Anger.
These are just boring.
They don't do anything funny.
Like that dreaded baby.
Why is he dreaded?
That's what I mean.
I jabbed you with my spikes.
She should be finished now.
Strong as I can be.
Indomitable.
Darkness.
Oh no. It's Getzerica.
Stupid.
It's horrible.
Believe me. I've tried.
She's funny.
Talk a lot. What are you calling me?
Talk a lot.
You fool.
You have no clue
how powerful I am.
You have no idea what you're getting into.
Rock she get in there.
Except for a
broken spinal
bone and
some missing teeth.
I'll be fine.
And they need nosh.
Now you have no hope.
Now you have one thing to do.
Stay off the ground.
Now I'll send in somebody to take care of you
in the air.
Weirdos.
Cute, but you're really not.
I don't know what's wrong with you.
Are you sure you'll work without break?
Well, maybe it'll snap back faster, but
it'll also be harder to...
You only have one rubber
band in your corns. Sorry.
She's stupid. If she keeps doing that
she'll never get anything accomplished.
These super family folds are so
easy to beat.
She'll be knocked out in a few moments.
I'll send corn flour.
Breathe in.
I think it said that.
Hey dude, it's like a hover car.
This is fun.
Dude, this is like...
with other nerds like them.
Hey dude, I'm a nerd. Are you a nerd too?
But don't call me a nerd
again.
Corn flour, what are you doing?
You're not a baby.
This is happening to my voice.
This is like one from my favorite movie.
H2O intolerance.
Then you'll find out.
This is fun. I like doing this.
Where's that baseball...
I'm confused. It's golf.
It's standing up.
Four stands for four teeth are knocked
out of your mouth.
Huh, cool.
Well, guess what Makuta?
Wait until you get a look at our new kids.
Ah, we just had four.
I don't even know
how many you have anyway.
So it's no use telling me. I can beat them anyway.
I can...
I've already taken on three. What do you have?
Two.
Yeah, two.
Well, I know that Bella,
Boar have the most. They have five now,
but they had to fight separately.
They only have five kids.
What happened to my nose?
I'm a nosh.
I'm so sure that they're gonna win.
I'm gonna knock myself out right now.
I'm gonna kick your butt.
Wait, no, that's five words.
Matimeo and um...
She said her name's Banila.
She said her name's Jules.
He said his name's...
Yeah, she said his name's...
Her name's Emerald.
That's Chaka and Banila.
Do I care?
Apparently yes, because...
Well, guess what?
You're going to be awakened because
Leroch's going to give you a...
A shot.
A big shot.
Jab.
Do what you did to, um...
Do to him what you did
to the doctor at your last appointment.
One leg chuck.
These guys are confusing me.
Banila.
I'm the bad doctor.
I'll give you a shot.
Banila.
She said her tail's like a whip.
Hey, wait a minute.
That's what Tahu says about a sword.
Whip, whip, whip, whip, whip.
Banila's good.
Who did this?
Butter.
Acid.
Start the music again.
This time.
How can you be so sure of that?
Let's just say, Makuta,
that we're in the second grade now.
Ugh.
Like that makes any difference.
Maybe it does, Makuta,
because you're not even in first.
Since the last time.
Oh, shut up!
You're already annoyed, and you're this far?
What, do you mean we're like halfway?
Not even close, Makuta.
We haven't even gotten to the Bionicles yet,
and there's more of them
Oh, no.
Why do you keep getting bigger?
It's no absolute sense.
You never get to play with each other and stuff.
You're always busy.
Yeah, and it's your fault, Makuta.
Pecker, pecker.
That's so fragile, Makuta.
I know it is.
Rokshi, get in there.
You're so independent on it.
What good are they?
Ugh, my energy.
Yes, I am Vorok.
I drain energy.
Apparently.
No, no, no, no, no. Not this time.
Whoa.
Big, ugly.
Dang it, too squishy.
It's too squishy to squash?
Hey, that's cool.
Too squishy to squash.
Multi-slash.
Chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee, chee.
Okay, you can stop now.
Swanbeam, you've learned a lot.
But you're still no match to what you did last time.
You made people laugh.
Even on my side.
Partly because you have the Rokshi out.
And they're always making us look bad.
Of course.
I'm supposed to be evil.
Gorok, your turn.
This is the swan we're supposed to be battling.
Where's your strength?
You don't even have anything to do.
Hey, you just knocked out that mask.
I know.
Why did you do that?
That's like so stupid.
God infected mask. I can't get it.
Oh, you're guarding it.
Got it.
Now your feathers will shatter.
Naked. Not a good thing.
That freaked off me.
What was that?
It is my energy.
No, actually it's Ponrok. He's walking around over there.
Is he taking a shower? Yes.
You always take showers. You're so stupid.
Oh, aren't I?
I killed Nokama.
I can kill you.
Apparently because you were in deep pain.
Die.
I gotta enlarge some of your energy.
Your legs are backwards.
Like a chicken.
Oh, shut up.
Lock him in.
What?
Is this some kind of prison?
Not exactly.
Get out of this torture thing.
Ugh, I can't fail.
But,
Makuta,
you have to.
What do you mean?
You're so stupid.
You can't fail now.
Well, I can cause you
the wrath of your wildest dreams.
Closer.
He walks.
No, not him.
Don't say his name.
It starts with a B.
No!
My heart. It bleeds.
B-A-B.
Don't go any further.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Forok, train his hands.
Are you quick before he says it?
Baby?
It's Serena.
It's baby.
I mean, not baby Ella.
Serena!
Get her!
What the heck are you doing?
Oh, am I?
Roxy!
Ha, now your feathers will turn to dust.
Will she stop?
Jeez.
Roxy!
Use your cupcake attack.
Will you stop it already?
Cupcakes are awesome.
Now, use Mega Confusion.
Psychic.
Mega Confusion.
You're golden, you rock.
Get her, cause she's black.
I'm using Confusion on you.
Now it's black and white.
No more colors for you.
Fixed it, but not that well.
Actually, that's much better.
What's going on?
I don't get what's going on.
What's happening?
What the heck are you doing?
You're not even talking at all.
She's so quiet.
Not even funny at all.
Okay.
Well, Roxy, eat her.
Shh.
Okay, that's just.
Eat that.
Eat it?
If the other 10% of you rounds break.
You know, more like negative 10%.
Whatever.
Try my oatmeal.
I can shatter your stomach with it.
You don't really need to do that.
Cause, well, you know,
cows really like your cereal
because now they only have three stomachs.
What do you mean?
What does that make it any better?
That they have three stomachs?
They like your cereal.
Don't you want people to hate your cereal?
Yeah.
Let's get to the point
why I'm here.
Mega laser.
You're an idiot.
You can't do anything funny.
Oh, that's very nice.
You sit there for 12 hours powering up
and then this attack
barely consumes
my body.
You've got to be the most annoying
thing this world has ever seen.
Oh, no, baby.
S.A.M.
You fu-
I don't like everything she says,
so just watch out for that.
Oh.
I won't even get her if you keep battling.
Roxy, get her!
Another baby?
Okay.
Poopy does not have an A in it.
Ow, you idiot!
What's she doing?
Why do I smell cake?
Ah, what a sticky mess!
Oh, shut up, will you?
Give her a shot.
At least you stopped.
Time for shawty.
With poison.
Stand still.
Do it now, you idiots.
It's actually fungus force shield.
Force field.
Better than mine.
Because we're not fighting you.
Knock her out.
Pikachu and Aku Aku.
Why are you blue?
Deal with it.
Excuse me, but can I make an arrangement?
I've still got my-
Excuse me, but you're not a doctor,
so you can't be handling this,
because you're not a professional.
Cheap sound effects.
That is not a very good sign.
I had a squeal.
Uh-oh.
Not good.
Yeah!
Hey, Grandma.
Don't you spoil the kids.
You spoil them rotten.
That's why Makuta hates them.
That's why Dad hates them.
Oh, yes, it is very unspoiling.
Some of the parents don't have to.
It's much easier that way.
Because, I mean, I fucking-
You have red on you.
Oh, isn't it just horribly being red?
Isn't that just forgetting about our weak spots,
you fool?
Exactly.
Because I wanted you to think I was forgetting.
Oh, so that I could just take it out,
and it would be much easier.
Oh, it's just so stupid.
Um, but forget-
We're always paying attention to the Rahkshi,
but then these guys
seem to be really powerful.
I'll kill him
until he's out of pieces.
Stupid mask.
Hey, what's this?
Um, what's my
best attack?
Invincibility attack.
Pumaga.
Can you stop it?
Nanda.
Wanna do our hurting?
Show you the power of
real fighters.
Pumpkin pie.
Past our wallets and more.
Here.
Fools, they don't know how to battle.
You don't even know our weakness.
Do you, you fools?
Okay, I'm gonna-
You don't even know how to do this.
You don't even know my weakness.
Read it.
Eat it.
You don't even know my weakness.
It's right there, you dummy.
But I can still scratch it.
Chew, chew, chew.
Can't seem to beat them.
Eat dolphins.
Especially blue ones.
You've been doing so well so far.
Nobody can stand
before us. Especially since
I've been battling
like I've fought Dr. Signore
all that time.
But now, I truly know
that I can beat the Super Family.
One of the new Transformers.
To the Super Family.
Yes.
Others like me, and the little ones
called the Mini-Cons,
have come to the Super Family
to bring you down, Makoto.
Just for that reason?
Yes. We live to battle.
Now.
Let us, let me introduce
my number one Mini-Con,
Joel. Look at that little thing.
You can't reach it, Dad.
Now let me transform.
Chew, chew, chew.
My name's Joel. My name's not Mini-Con.
It's much easier to battle.
Star Saber.
Stop nicking me, you little mosquito.
Now.
With the Star Saber,
I will take you down, Makoto.
Chew, chew, chew.
Thanks for doing that.
Boink.
Now I'll get you.
You're small.
You're big. You're skinny.
Chew, chew, chew.
I don't need this.
You gonna take a break?
You're real nice.
I guess.
What the?
Since Joel attached to me,
she gave me this special power.
Hyper Hydraulic Cannon.
Transforming.
Hydraulic Cannon.
You can still fight karate
like in my vehicle mode.
It's possible.
I hot shot Mr. Not Evil.
Chew.
Gotcha.
Hey, this is fun.
Wait a minute. Let me adjust something.
Put it back into its socket.
I brought the boom box along with me.
Let's just put it in and find out.
Whoa, what's that freaky music?
I don't have the Transformers music.
I don't know how to get it.
What?
Don't worry.
I'll figure it out myself.
I am Blur.
Wait a second. I need to use it as a key.
Put this fire place in here.
Can you Blur?
Okay. Tell me when you want to come out.
Okay. Just wait a second.
I gotta fix my computer.
This is so annoying.
This is taking too long.
Blur.
It kind of crashed in half.
Now let's go.
Let's go.
I can't stop the inspection.
Yes.
All the Transformers.
No, it's not Road Rash.
I got the catalog here.
Get the catalog that has...
Not that one. That one's really new.
Get the one right there.
See what's your name.
The last two Transformers wasted too much time.
Yeah. They took a half an hour to play.
It comes out from here.
And goes to the back.
And then I shoot ya.
Yeah.
Powerful shield in the world.
They attack.
Well, except Hyper Supernova Beam.
And some evil attacks.
But I'm not sure what they are.
But anyway, it's a very strong shield.
And that's a coincidence because it almost fits around my arm.
A mini me.
It curves at every mark there is in my body.
Nice.
It like fits right there.
Like this.
I'm watching the dust.
I'm not trying to whack you.
Okay, this is getting boring.
Let's fight. Boing.
I don't have any cards.
Get back to your normal forms.
Try to block Ku Rock into, um,
Ku Rock into, um,
the bad guys.
So, um, then they'll get angry against each other.
Let me knock some sense into you.
Nui Jaa, I'm back.
I want to see how well you do against the Rock Sheep.
I took them, so you're not independent.
Let's fight, guys.
I've got little guys.
Okay, I'll throw you.
Aiming good.
Oh, and then you threw him.
I know.
Sorry.
Did he get caught behind your head?
You may have to feed. You will never defeat me.
I'll get him.
Do I need to get the Evil Shot Doctor in here?
No.
Evil Shot Doctor. I mean, Lairock.
I am the Evil Shot Doctor.
Do I need to give you a
Shot fight.
You can't knock a Rock Sheep out.
You are part of the very substance of Makuta.
Oh, come here, Shab.
Dang it, she's turning into a playing mode.
Shab, stupid Mini-Con.
Hey, I got squeaky legs.
Good shot, Con Rock.
Yes, I am the master of explosions.
I'll take your head.
Transform and help us out.
Put this right in there.
Normally, if you consider broken,
you'd be thrown out of the window.
Then the kid's mom would go,
Oh, this is junk. Throw it out the window.
Actually, we wouldn't need to worry about this
if we just took off one of your heads
and you were one old plastic thing.
Shab, you took our heads.
That's a crime, you know.
Get smoked, Shab.
What are you doing?
Get away from me, you little worm.
You can't do anything to me with that.
What would that be?
My Lego wood.
I'll get you.
The last of the Transformers enters.
Yes, Optimus Prime and Jetfire.
Mini-Cons, come on.
Hold trailer.
Jetfire and I will combine.
Now, let us battle.
So he can fight his two little Mini-Cons.
Let us battle.
You two Mini-Cons,
plug in Commodore.
I have a baby.
You make me so angry.
You think you can beat me.
I didn't say cake.
Now,
jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab.
Jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab.
Die, Jetfire.
They just have different powers.
That just seem familiar.
But,
thus, we are powerful low-rock.
Jeez, I haven't seen
myself in a while.
Yeah, cause you're always hanging out in the zone.
Sword, sword, sword.
Karma, karma, karma.
We play with Krata a lot.
What's a Krata?
You should know, Makuta. You're the Rock Sheep.
They should be using Krata.
Hey, little bro, you shouldn't have said that.
Oh, sorry.
Set that up.
Gift your stinger, bro.
I knew it.
I know you are. We've seen you plenty of times before.
Not like our first meeting.
You've battled.
You've battled, I guess.
That's funny, cause I like jabbing into
Mwaka's head with this thing.
I got lots of cool Krata. I mean,
karma. I'm not used to saying that.
That's weird. You're putting on opposite sides
of your Tsubo.
Ooh, stare here.
Ugh, my head's
crooked.
You look cute,
but you're stupid.
Stinger attached.
Ready? Those swords.
Um, what do you want to call it?
Ooh, that one hurt. I stuck it up his eye.
You know, you shouldn't really be talking about
them. This won't be rated G anymore.
Cack, cack, cack, cack.
Yarr. We have some really weird, most powerful
attacks this time.
What do you mean?
Cause some of those powerful attacks are like scratch
and stuff. That's weird.
I guess.
We have little capes, but that's where we keep our
Krona. Speaking of Krona, we don't
have it. It'd be funny if we had a little
rubber band to keep it. Oh, we're supposed to be
Krona characters. Well,
I'm gonna fling my Krona.
I mean, Krona.
Now my turn.
But, bro, you gotta, but dude,
you gotta get, well, yeah, bro, you gotta
get your other Krona in. Oh, this one's
awesome. It's the voice Krona.
Yeah. I'm
Venkai, and I- What do you call them?
Maskheads. Oh, yeah.
I need a Krona now.
Wrong Krona in, bro. I've always been doing the wrong
thing. Let's switch them quick. Hey, dude.
Hey, like, I'll try.
Shielding. You fool.
And I'll scrape this Krona off.
Reach it. Will not pass
by, um, Occupy, or
whatever, uh, you.
That's weird. Chuck.
There. Now they're all under our
control. Hey?
No!
This one's like a
Radar Sense Krona, even though they're
not Krona-Kal. What are
Krona-Kal? They're updated
Krona for the Bohrok Ka. I wish
they were Bohrok Va-Kal, but
I guess you can consider them super
friendly. Knock two of his Krona
out. Years.
You can't stop me now. Chomp.
Ah! I lost my
Krona.
Ding-der, ding-der, ding-der, ding-der,
ding-der, ding-der.
Ars Arcadia!
Swords dare- I have failed.
Ding-ding-ding-ding-ding.
Krona again. Can you fix him?
I can't right now, but I'll
try. If we win.
A real pain in the butt.
We need a rubber band to keep this.
Yeah, now I got my Radar Krona.
I can anticipate any
of your moves.
Just as long as you
do them correctly. Use Sight!
Now I'm gonna hack your nose.
I can do that with you too.
This is cool.
I'll hack him, and you hack him.
I failed.
Now it's time for the
Bohrok. Yeah!
Oh, that
reminds me. I'll just need one
this time. And that will be
Lirok. Thanks for sending
him in, Makuta. What?
My power is poison.
It is? No, yours is
acid. Well,
kind of. Now I'll get
you. Ha! Uh-oh.
Forgot the Krona. Load him up.
Now I'll just put this in.
Where's my favorite? A steel
looking one. Steel, steel, steel. Okay.
Dang, dang, dang, dang.
Dig!
Get your Master Bohrok
and Krona off. Then
Kai don't need him. Because
you used my Krona. That's why you're
always,
you're never not good. Take care of him, Nubok.
I'll take care of Makuta.
That's cheap. Now I'll take
this Tunneling one. There you go!
That was a nice shot. See you, Makuta.
I'm gonna come up somewhere.
Guard your mass.
Nubok, watch the skies.
He could be anywhere.
He has to come up to breathe sometime.
But Makuta, this Krona
allows me to breathe.
I have to get him.
I don't know what was happening. Okay.
Tunnel again. Use your
underground sense. You still can't take my Krona
out. Get to him.
Get many of Nubok's Krona
while he's gone. If you take him off.
Do I have another?
Dang!
But I do have this
translation one.
The telepathy one.
I can make you scared.
Are you my conscience?
I see this
Bohrok.
You shouldn't attack.
But my dad says to.
I'm your guide.
Now I'll just have to use my flying Krona.
You have to use a Krona to fly?
Yeah.
What's the point in having one if you can already fly?
Kick.
Kick. Kick. Kick.
It's like a space walk.
That gives me an idea.
I'm gonna fling you.
Now I can't use that one.
So I'll have to get another one.
Hey! This is another flying Krona.
Oh shut up! I don't need your
smart aleck. He's laying over there
like he's dead.
You were laying still for a while.
I went from the Krona. I don't want it to turn off.
You're not wearing a Krona.
Wrong wind. You threw him in the wrong wind.
See that's the problem with Mixer.
I have a clearance worker.
Hey cool that's different.
Looks like a howl if you ask me.
It has the same power as a howl.
Only a little bit more powerful.
Drill!
He's drilling.
Whack!
Oh it's a translation.
I used to think I had this purple Krona.
But those are...
What do you call it?
No it's not a rock sheet.
Um.
Uh.
I have failed.
Mental shock!
Ugh I have failed.
It's up to me.
Dang it.
I have failed.
Acid venom.
D'oh.
Rock shock.
Yeah man.
We are so gonna totally whoop your butt.
Give us some luck.
Knock this over.
Uh you heard this ring.
I turned my staff around.
It's a really good mask picker.
It's good for this too.
Um infected mask stick thingy.
Infected mask sticky.
Stick thing who?
I'm gonna hit you on the head with the infected mask sticky.
Stick thing.
It's like a tongue twister.
Infected mask sticky thing.
If it was sticky I could go like this.
I'll get you into my horn.
D'oh.
Hey she doesn't have it.
Yeah that's because I control her.
Well not yet.
This is gonna be fun.
Oh darn you mister.
I'll need another chrono.
Myself or chrono?
Head shave.
Little jet pack with knives on your.
You can take them off if you want.
Arm's twisted.
Gonna have to do something.
Infected mask on and I'm attached to it.
Two of our chronos.
Make sure they don't fall out.
Make sure he doesn't drag my head into his slobbery mouth.
Mmm.
Now I'll shave her head.
The rocks you have mohawks.
Yeah they do when you look at them straight ahead.
Cool.
You're criticized.
Give me back my strength chrono in Makuta.
Dang it.
You say that funny but you're a mess.
On now.
I was about to say that.
Cool.
I heard you.
So drink it up and you'll get drunk.
Cool.
But kids don't drink.
It's not even 21 yet.
Really? How old are you?
You can drive.
But there's no cars around.
And even if there was I'd smash it.
Hey you can drive.
I don't know how this will help me.
I can talk to the ground.
I'm talking to it.
With this chrono you can talk to the landscape and other things.
Do this dude.
It's knock knock jokes.
Knock knock jocks.
Okay.
Chainsaw thingy on my hand.
Chainsaw thingy on your hand who?
I'm going to slice you in half with my chainsaw thingy on my hand.
You can use those to channel your powers.
I'm going to use an earthquake.
You said channel my powers right?
But there's channels on TV's
and you need a remote to do that.
It's a homonym.
Yes it's a homonym.
I don't care.
I don't know.
I don't even know these things.
I'll jab you in the eye.
They don't hurt when you touch them.
They're like little bags.
Our eyes are like little bags full of cold water
and when you push them there's this little bag
inside our head shell
and it pops up and releases the chrono.
Get those hand shields away from your head.
It's chronoing me.
I have my shielding chrono in.
Try to attack me.
Voice chrono.
Oh dang that's not it.
Cool.
Hey cool. I look funny.
Yeesh.
You are.
Go take a shower. You're dirty.
Hey. Rubber band in the back of my neck.
Hey cool.
It was like it fell off by accident
and knocked his mask off and got stuck on.
This arm obeys Makoto
but this arm obeys him.
Ringing.
Roar. I am Tanra. Roar.
You want some claws?
So dumb.
Red is so not my color.
But yellow is so my color.
I know.
Not my color.
Doesn't it look pretty cool to me?
Shoo shoo.
Hey yeah it does cause red doesn't really go with white
but white goes with everything so it does.
Oosh.
I am flying now.
It's that one with the big cheeks.
I like the big cheeks.
That's the tongue thing.
It feeds all your senses.
You can see better. You can smell better.
You can taste better. You can hear better.
You can feel better.
Well it isn't really good if you get attacked.
But your sense of alertness is heightened too.
I smell chocolate.
A thousand miles what?
Makoto let me ask you something.
Where is your butt?
I don't think that was chocolate.
But it tasted like chocolate.
Yeah.
It was chocolate.
And I tasted it.
Um of course. I'm a co-Korani.
She is.
If he says he can hear ice cream then he can hear ice cream.
She's a co-Korani.
Of course she can hear ice cream.
It failed.
Yeah.
It does.
I don't like ringing rings.
So it's uh.
Slashing with myself.
This just in. I got an idea.
Very ingenious indeed.
You know what that means Makoto?
I'm not going to get hit in your mouth and pull out the doobie.
To rock them.
Time out in jail lock.
We are going to totally broke your butt Makoto.
We are the leaders of Borah.
You won't beat me as easily as last time.
It's time.
I'm going to fling a crown at him.
I had to do that.
Head's going to hit it.
I am going to fall with the crown and destroy it easily.
Should I fling it?
Yep.
Cause they miss.
Don't have to go on exactly.
Big spot.
They really, really miss.
I have daddy.
Ching, ching, ching, ching.
Where are the Roxy here?
Well, how come they were-
This part of me was, um, uh, fighting.
Chrono flinging.
Control Bohrok, I can release Chrono.
Gonna get ya.
It's dangerous to play with weapons, you know, kids.
Sweep to them.
Integrate their eyes.
I like the foam.
Knock three of this Chrono out.
I'm gonna use this flying Chrono, and this radar, and this sense Chrono.
Oh, better yet, six more of her.
Marine.
Giant.
I'm reviving my Chrono.
You can only do that once.
With two.
I can't do that.
I'm not trained enough.
Oh, yeah, that's because I have a staff.
Now I'll put this one.
This one's a flying Chrono.
Oh, I can fly and be Makuta's voice.
This is my lucky Chrono.
Do you see?
Oh.
Do you see it?
Not.
See it?
It's pretty.
Get your mask back on.
Stop saying that, Makuta.
It's stupid.
Now I must put.
Smack in the head.
Ching, ching, ching, ching, ching, ching.
I dropped that one.
Now I'll use this crack.
Even though that one got knocked out.
You can't beat us.
Yes, we can.
Mega.
Hang in there.
The more I stay.
Makuta talking.
He's an old senior now.
Old senior.
What's different?
Daddy's dumb.
Some dumb ladies.
Me?
Who's me?
Back off.
Me?
He's a 003 and 004.
Who's 003?
I forget.
He's younger.
I like being bigger.
I'm taller than you.
How dare he?
Her.
Kick.
You get yours.
I can bend my knees just like you.
See?
It doesn't affect the Rahkshi.
Okay.
Bend knee.
Kick.
Give me name instead of Makuta.
Don't come off that easily.
Oh.
Thank you.
Oh yeah.
This is a pretty cool mask.
Sn 1964 diff.
Knock three of his car now.
Makuta does that attack all the time, but it can't affect the brouhaha, you dodo head.
Dodos are smart, they're extinct.
If they are smart they'd be here by now.
Then he's a-
They're ice armoria.
Yes.
The acid-
It freezes them.
No.
It acids them and then it freezes them.
It's like freeze dry.
Freeze dry.
Or freeze burn.
Freeze burn.
Yeah.
Freezer burn.
Don't you?
Yep.
Don't look.
My thing's on my arm.
Here.
I'll get you.
Give me back those chronic stones.
Who's your daddy?
I haven't seen that movie in a while.
Don't you just love it when he smacks people?
Now you have to give me back the chronic stone.
Dang it.
Take a break.
I'm gonna meditate.
Um.
What happened?
What's going on?
Um.
Oh my god.
Break.
It was a really big break.
Quick.
Oh yeah.
That was like one second.
Ugh.
Trash!
I'm going to get ya.
You got a lot of your Krono
while you were gone.
I wasn't eating.
He said he.
You're out.
You didn't swallow the thingy.
I gotcha.
I've still got his energy in here.
Now, drain your energy.
Did you?
I'm falling apart because I'm running out of kaita energy.
Then you hurt me.
I'm dead.
Fireball machine gun.
You shouldn't have that toy.
Losing kaita energy.
Action.
Kaita energy.
Kick me.
I like kicking.
Kick.
Losing kaita energy.
Yeah, I gotta blow mine.
Kaita energy.
So far, I've lost all of my new block power.
Catch him.
Kaita.
Knock it out.
She nailed it.
At really close.